right just think about swimming through
your brain
as opposed to being only able to see a
flat image of your brain
right it makes all the difference in the
world
[Music]
ron schilling thank you so much for
joining me in 20 minute leaders
nice to be here great to have you and
you know you have such a wealth of
experience over 35 years
in the medical imaging technology sector
you've
you know you've led incredible
achievements within toshiba medical and
the general electric medical
master's at princeton a phd back in
polytechnic now it's nyu
ron give me a brief rundown over of what
you've done in this
medical devices technology industry
and i'd love to spend the next 19
minutes or so learning myself as much as
i can
over this industry okay well i
started out at general electric in the
medical field
after having come out and coming out of
the semiconductor field
and um ge wanted me for semiconductors
but we didn't make a go of that because
there was a um
a very bad market condition in 74.
in 76 they asked me again how about the
cat scanner
and i said oh my goodness what is that i
asked friends of mine they said very
high risk
but very high reward reward if it does
work properly
and sure enough ct became an incredible
reward for all
the thing about it at general electric
was that the
general manager of the business that i
was in the
overall medical business had an
opportunity to become chairman of the
company
if the ct business did well that was
jack welch a very famous name
today unfortunately we lost him about
eight months ago
and i came in there and took on
the service the the marketing
organization
for the gect program and i went and
spoke to customers
because having come from the
semiconductor industry you always got
out there to talk to customers so i have
a question ron just paint me a picture
when where what year are we and what's i
mean is ct a common thing around the us
at that point
no no no no and that was 1976
ct was just getting started so and and
today it's practically at
every hospital right everywhere you go
okay so and so you're really you're
really a pioneer in
introducing the ct to the american
market right
right so in getting out there and
talking to customers
they told me that they were very
concerned because they this is a new
device for them
right they were used to basic x-ray
and but what they explained to me was
that ct is about systems
applications and service not just for
technology
so to me the whole game was all about
quality
quality of getting our systems to work
the very best of anyone else's system
right we may not have had the very best
technology
but because we had a large organization
and x-ray
we had the best performance out there in
the field
and we won very big we were number one
in the united states
a lot of companies came into the
marketplace
they went out of the marketplace right
leaving the standard companies
working with us what was the deciding
factor
in in helping ge win aside of course you
you're leading the endeavor but
but what what was what were the deciding
factors that made you
come on top versus your competitors in
retrospect
it was the quality on the images
it was purely the quality of the of the
thought of the product
absolutely and we worked very closely
with customers that was another thing
we called it the clinical technical tie
that is there's a clinical need and we
understood the customer's need almost as
well as they did
because we spoke to many customers and
clinical technical timings bring the
technology
to the customer situation and create the
right solution for the right job
okay so we had the best brain imaging we
had the best body imaging we had the
best knee image
etc etc etc we were very applications
oriented
right and that was a very very
important aspect of that something that
i came away with from the semiconductor
industry
wow then i got as i moved up into ge's
medical organization i was in charge of
strategic planning
and at that time ge was like number
three in the world
wow and jack welch again to become
chairman
wanted us to become number one in the
world that was his goal
and to do that i looked around
took some calculations of the various
markets in the world
and it was very clear that
you had to get japan and i looked around
in japan and i found that huge packard
the company i had a lot of respect for
already had a partner called yokogawa
very famous group yokogawa hillary pack
and yhp
we became yge yokogawa general electric
and we with yokagawa we became number
one
in a japanese market for a period of
time
ahead of toshiba ahead of hitachi
shimazu
didn't she go on to work for toshiba
later on
didn't you go on to didn't you go on to
be a senior vice president
at toshiba later on yes absolutely
very nice well they
knew me they knew me very well exactly
but i'll tell you an interesting thing
while i was fighting them in ct
i was also their partner in in
um medical sys
equipment having to do with um
or whatever they call it uh cardiac type
systems
so we were already working with them
right at that time
so but in ct we were enemies
so so i think it's interesting how in
these huge
huge companies uh you could be
collaborators and partners on some
fields but then you have other
other market aspects where you're
complete competitors
and it's and it's and it's a natural
thing right
by the way it took a lot of trust i'm
sure
a lot of trust and no one violated
that trust another thing that was very
important in those days to again become
the
leader of the mark in the world market
was to get a position in china
and i led a team to china and we won to
get the very first
whole body scanner into the china market
in beijing hospital
1980 and that was really exciting i
cannot tell you
because everyone was there for that
everyone wanted it
there were eight companies and i was
asked do you want to be first or last
i said i'll be last going in wait wait
pay me the picture
there's eight companies pitching to this
hospital exactly
okay i want to hear the story tell me
the story again
well there were eight and we came in
last
as in literally you walked last into the
room to show your product
well it was over a period of weeks okay
yes we came in
to show them what we could do right and
and
um at the end of that they said we want
to go to contract
wow so i sent my team home i worked
in the embassy the us embassy in beijing
wow worked up the contracts
sent the contracts home and the team
that was by fax if you remember in those
days there was no nothing else
and the team looked at it and they
turned it down
they turned down the deal and that's
when i made one of the biggest decisions
in my lifetime i
said i'm signing this deal anyway
and i signed it subject to subject to
approval by senior vice president dr
walter l rob
i then went home with the documents
put it on the table there was the whole
senior team
and walt rob looked at the document
never even looked up to the other guys
at the table
took the pen and signed it
now how did i know that he would
probably do that we did not communicate
his boss was jack welch
if jack welch found out that he had in
his hands the opportunity
to take china and he turned it down that
would not have been a good thing
unfortunately by the way both welch and
walt raw passed away over the last
year two spectacular people
but i have to ask did you know did you
think through this
as you were sitting in the embassy and
you were wondering should i
you know go alone in this battle and and
you know because the outcome could have
been you come home
you bring this to the table and you
could get fired fired
yes you know what that would have been
worthwhile
because then i'd make a big deal of that
story that's for sure
no no it was obviously you know you got
to always look at no matter what love
what is the right thing to do and you
have to understand the players that
you're working with that you report to
and it was that's why i'm saying it was
one of the most incredible experiences
on that plane home i was just so
exhilarated about the what what that
scene was going to be when i came in
there
why did they turn it down they turned it
down
because of the fact that
they're very conservative they work for
ge all their lives
taking on the china deal was a major
risk
people in large companies don't take on
large risks
right i'm a semiconductor guy i was only
around for four to five years
for me this is the way we did things in
the semiconductor world
right right everything was a risk
everything was a risk
anyway that was just terrific um
i then ended up running the x-ray
business in ge
um then an opportunity came up
in the area of mri and a company called
diasonix came
after me turns out the ceo
a very close friend of mine from years
back
in school uh asked me to run the mri
division of diasonics they already had
x-ray systems and they had ultrasound
and um that brought me to california
and it brought me to another program by
the way that ct scanner i forgot to
mention we did the final development at
ucsf
were you no you you studied you studied
your
your bachelor somewhere ge ge
was in milwaukee okay whoever we
worked with the main site at ucsf also a
site
in milwaukee okay well with isonix
again i came back to ucsf
so you could see either way
yes and uh the research team that we had
was from ucsf okay
dr leon kaufman and his team were a
group within
ucsf that came and worked with us
and who was my major competitor ge
so when you're a ge your biggest
competitor was toshiba when you're at
diasonix your major
your biggest competitor is ge and when
you're in toshiba who's your biggest
competitor
the world the world
now again again it was ge of course
g siemens and phillips and and and the
beautiful thing about
um the the mri business for us
is that i realized we're a small company
if we're a small company universities
are very expensive to work with
so we can only be very focused on a few
of them
then there's the hospital market right
they're much too conservative to buy
from us
yeah because we're a risk for them
but then there's the private market we
created the private
market those are private docs who feel
mri is just what they want and they
wanted it for
shoulders they wanted it for hips they
didn't want to do brain work like the
universities would do
right and we went after the private
market
and that made us second in the united
states only the general electorate
wow it was an incredible situation
the other thing we did is we we sold
them on a paper study basis we created
that at that time
so instead of spending two three million
dollars for the whole system
we put the system in
we had a finance company work with us on
that
but we made our bread from
the dollar the paper study interesting
what is it what does that mean paper
study oh for every study that they do
they pay us
incredible i love that i love that model
yeah
well today it's called subscription it's
called all kinds of things
right but back in 1983 it didn't exist
except for us
wow the other thing that happened there
is
a place you know md anderson is a very
famous center by the way
located in texas they wanted an mri
and we were working with a group called
texas medical equipment
another a player in the private market
who had a number of sites our sites
so they put in our system into a
building near
md anderson and we then supplied mv
anderson
wow the other thing we did is we had
vans
we put a system in a van we'd roll that
van around the community
the docks and each of those sites
would have a workstation of ours inside
the hospital so just picture this
michael customer comes into the van
the imagery is taken it's sent
streamed a lot of streaming today
we were streaming then 1984 1985.
there was no internet back then
streaming it inside the hospital
and inside the hospital the doctor just
went to the workstation was which was
next door to his office as far as he was
concerned the system was in the hospital
incredible incredible it was really
incredible
incredible ron you know we have we have
just a few minutes left and and
it's such a unique privilege to to be
able to speak to somebody who's
who's a really a pioneer in all these
devices you know
and my my girlfriend's father is a
radiologist so i'm getting exposed to
all these incredible devices and
technology and all of a sudden i get to
speak
to somebody who helped bring them to
market uh you know back
back in the day and i'd love to get your
input what what
what earned secrets or what insight do
you have
from your impressive career over the
last 35 years
in this industry what can i take away as
a young entrepreneur
from your experiences well the first
thing is vision
and an example of vision is when i saw
the opportunity to instead of having
flat images
have images in open 3d space
where the doctor can uh interact with
the
object right just think about swimming
through your brain
as opposed to being only able to see a
flat image of your brain
right it makes all the difference in the
world
having that kind of a vision got us into
something called
interactive mixed reality yeah
now becoming a very big thing we've been
at it for five or six years already
the other thing is being a dot collector
a connect connector what is a dot
connector
well there's radiology there's surgery
and realizing that radiology and surgery
need to come together
so when we showed them this open 3d
space imaging and a radiologist said
oh with this i can speak intelligently
to a surgeon
and then a surgeon said just a month
later
wow i've never used a work station
before i said why not
he said i've never opened up a patient
to see the 2d view
right right everything's 3d in surgery
yeah so our technology was the bridge
between radiology and surgery
wow we've been so many papers on that
and that's why we're leading in that
whole area
and the last point is being a coach
it's the being a director coach i think
is my life from now on and i'm already
involved in a number of startups uh
which will utilize
the the technology from the company echo
pixel
where they're looking things in open 3d
space one is scoliosis
you can't you have to use three
dimensions in scoliosis
and the reason they have so many
problems is because they use
two-dimensional views
and things like that right so those are
the aspects
that i think are all very important
vision being a dot connector
and being a coach ron are those three
words that you would choose also for
yourself
of how you would describe yourself oh
absolutely
i love it i'm always looking for dance
so visionary dot connector
and the last one and the last one is
coach
the last one is coach ron i want to take
this opportunity to thank you again for
your generous time
uh inspiring to hear how you how you
helped lead this industry
and i think it's it's just so much fun
that you got to work with
with all these different companies who
ended up being competitors to each other
and the world
yet you always came out on top so i
think that shows quite a bit about
the visionary the dot connectedness and
the coach that you that you bring with
you
ron thank you very much we did you know
i i wanted to get to talk also about you
you're very involved with the j ventures
that were both at we didn't get to that
but uh
but definitely a it's great to have you
there and i love learning from you all
the time through all the work we do
there
and so thank you again and have a great
day
have a great day and stay healthy thank
you so much see you soon take care
bye bye